Hey guys, what's up?
Good to see you.
Excellent application of the eye black.
I love it, good job.
Thanks, I did mine
in a real macho kind of way.
I was like, (grunts).
Yeah, he was like,
I want it to look like I don't care.
He went high, I went low.
(laughter)
Listen, I don't know about you, Tiki,
but I am so excited for this weekend.
I'm a big football fan, as you know.
Where will you be watching the game?
I will actually be in CBS watching it
from the broadcast center.
I'm gonna be paying attention as everybody is
to the big stories that are going on around this game.
I mean, the Super Bowl was always fantastic
but this is the first time
that the actual home team is hosting the Super Bowl.
The Tampa Bay Buccaneers taking on the defending
champion, Kansas City Chiefs.
Tiki!
I can't, is that okay that I do that?
I can't but shimmy.
Yes, I love that.
It makes me feel good, so go ahead.
Okay good, 'cause
that's what you inspire.
You too, Ross, go ahead.
Okay, let's talk quarterbacks.
It's the Buccaneers against the Chiefs this weekend.
And everyone's talking about the GOAT, Tom Brady
versus the future GOAT Patrick Mahomes.
Now what's the most exciting thing about this matchup, Tiki?
Pat Mahomes is the second coming.
He's the new face of football.
He's a good looking kid, he's biracial.
He is already got a Superbowl MVP, a league MVP.
And he's trying to take Tom Brady
off of that mantle, which he's been sitting on
for two decades now.
So it's a great storyline.
It's also gonna be a great matchup as well.
Patrick Mahomes apparently watched Tom Brady
when he was six years old play
for the New England Patriots and he really admired him.
And so I think that just adds this awesome Shakespearian
cool level of you're going against someone
that you idolized as a kid.
Tom Brady's never been more on top of his game.
He proved to everyone that is,
with all due respect to his team
and his coach that he can do anything anywhere at any time.
And so I think the pairing,
and I know Tom Brady has said just the nicest things
about Patrick Mahomes.
So if you love, but you're having to, you know, fight.
It's just like, oh, it's just so rich
and I'm so excited.
And it's all about legacy.
I think this is Tom Brady's 10th Super Bowl,
it could be his seventh win
or Patrick could get a second win in a row.
And I think history will be made in this Super Bowl.
And not only in the game, but during the halftime show
as well, Tiki, we know The Weeknd is pulling
out all the stops for this performance.
He spent like $7 million of his own money
to make it amazing.
That's right.
And Pepsi just released a little promo.
This is a glimpse.
Take a look.
We're seeing this for the first time.
(dramatic music)
What we create changes us.
Every performance a new chapter,
every stage a new beginning.
I think it's gonna be great.
Tiki, when you've been to Super Bowls before,
what do you think makes a great halftime show?
I think that the energy and the performers
who come and they give it to everybody there.
Now, the crowd is only going to be 22,000.
It's not gonna be full capacity-
Still a lot.
But I think
everybody's going to be excited about The Weeknd,
but it's a good thing it's not on a Monday,
because The Weeknd wouldn't have made sense.
(laughter)
Look at you, Tiki, with a joke.
It can be a three day.
A three day weekend.
People take Monday
off anyways, right?
Right.
Nobody knows what the days of the weeks are anymore.
Good point.
All right, we have to talk about the main event,
which is the other main event.
I'm a big football fan
and I love the Super Bowl and I watch it every year
but I also love that commercials.
Preach.
And this year it's gonna be different
because biggies like Budweiser are sitting
out and donating the money instead to vaccination programs.
But we still got some surprises
and we're gonna look at a sneak peek at one right now.
Amazon is relaunching their Alexa with a brand new shape
and look, and they premiere this steamy ad on Sunday.
You ready guys?
I haven't seen it.
Yeah.
Alexa, dim the lights.
♪ But I'll save you a seat ♪
Alexa, lights on, Alexa, lights on!
Add bath oil to my shopping list.
Alexa no, don't do that.
(laughter)
Alexa, do that, yeah.
I mean, I'm like, boi-oi-oi-oi-oing!
Was it Michael B. Jordan, right?
Yes.
Tiki, what do you think when you see this?
Look, are they gonna allow Alexa to take on
the voices of some of these stars?
Because I know Patrick Dempsey is my wife's it guy
and he's filming something in New Jersey right now.
So I'm like, don't go over there.
You don't need to go watch it, you don't need to go watch.
That actually made me a little uncomfortable.
I felt for the husband.
It's probably not for a straight male,
that said, I will say this.
(laughter)
I am terrified.
Like I have my Siri off, her and I aren't besties anyway.
I am Orwellian phobic.
I don't want stuff being listened to in my house.
I'm not into the Orwellian voice mechanisms in my house.
So when you sell it as Michael B. Jordan
it makes it a little more enticing.
Yeah, you'll listen to him, for sure.
Before we go, we're gonna do a rush
of fun facts about the Super Bowl.
Oh!
(party whistle)
Oh, fun!
Oh, well, there you go.
Okay, Tiki, you're our quarterback.
So three, two, one, hike it!
Here we go.
All right, here's the first one for you, Drew and Ross.
First, this is the most viewed halftime show of all time.
Is it A: Lady Gaga,
B: Janet and Justin or C: Katy Perry?
Okay, so I want to say Lady Gaga
because it's the most recent of the three,
but I think it's Justin and Janet.
That was the one everyone talked about.
Drew?
I'm gonna go A: Gaga.
Which is weird, 'cause we always pick the same thing.
Okay, what is it, Tiki?
You're both wrong.
It's Katy Perry.
What?
120 million viewers.
Lady Gaga was a close second with 117 million viewers.
I think YouTube of Janet and Justin,
that was probably like 5 billion views.
But next one.
52% of people surveyed say
that they will give up this for their team
if their team could win the big game.
Is the answer A: Their annual bonus,
B: A year of vacation days or C: Their entire 401k.
I have to think it's vacation days, right?
You've giving up money for your team to win?
I'll go with you Ross, on vacation day.
Lock us in on B.
You're both correct,
congratulations!
Yay!
52% of people say that they would give up vacation days.
31% said their annual bonus
and only 3% given up their 401ks.
'Cause I like the Seahawks, but I like the coin too.
(laughter)
All right, last one for you guys.
By the numbers this is the most popular halftime
Super Bowl snack.
Is it A: Pigs in a blanket,
B: Wings or C: Pizza?
I think it has to be B wings.
Everyone's in the mood for wings on Super Bowl Sunday.
B: Wings.
Congratulations, you're both correct,
it is B: Wings.
1.4 billion wings will be consumed on Sunday.
Did you say 1.4 billion wings?
1.4 billion, 1.4 billion.
How many chickens is that?
It's a lot, it's a lot.
Alexa, can you divide that by two?
I have to say that this was so fun
and we've been looking forward
to this all week, Tiki!
And we can't wait for the big game
and we'll be with you in spirit.
Thank you guys.
And just thank you so much.
Tiki Barber!
Thank you, Tiki, great to see you!
Great to see you guys again.
(upbeat music)